well you know they say everyone's got a
plan until they get punched in the face
yeah and that's what happened last week
by mike tyson the guy in the flight did
you see that that was that pissed me off
so bad like that i watched that kid he
was really aggravating i don't know why
the stewardess didn't come over and go
you
sit down shut up yeah i mean something i
mean he would really had a record
apparently he had a record and he's been
i don't know there were some stories
about the guy that came up about him
having a record did you see that tyler
or no
yeah he has several different charges
he's been arrested for look yeah clearly
the guy's got a screw loose if you're
talking [ __ ] to mike tyson
clearly you've got a uh you know a loud
mouth that you're drinking
so here's my question ddp you're a
massive dude i mean
how often does somebody say what's up
you gotta go nobody tried something to
you never everybody they know who i am
yeah and the people who don't you know
you can see by the way i carry myself
i'm not the guy
i know you do say do something with my
wife
that's a different story but with me you
can't piss me off i just you know i
eliminate yeah your voice what do you
think i want to get i really don't get
that ever because like i mean i help a
lot of people but what do you think was
going through tyson's mind i mean i'm
talking oh my putting yourself is in a
position of a high profile major athlete
tough guy which you are
and tyson is sitting on the plane you
know doing his things probably on a
mushroom or two it's certainly high
and this jackass is just going off on
him i'm getting put yourself in tyson
he's getting the
and go can you move that [ __ ] yeah or
can you shut him up you know he's
bothering my wife
because i'm not going to let him step
into my space
you know you know when you're in this
scenario there there's there's an
ulterior motive it's not just maybe in
the beginning he was a little excited
about it but after a while
he's just being an [ __ ] you know he
has no respect for anyone's space and
he's got some kind of issue you know but
the stewardesses
you know they're pretty strict these
days you know since 9 11. you know it's
a different answer how did the student
was he in first class the internet never
loses it's undefeated look at this right
here
marshall and then mike tyson beat the
[ __ ] out of some guy right
how did the stewardess not show up how
did other people not see what was about
to go on again i thought i'm looking at
that i'm going is this a work i mean
where is
and mike doesn't deserve to be treated
like that in any way shape or form you
talk about a guy who's turned his life
around thank god i interviewed him for
an hour yeah and it was one of the
coolest things talking to that guy if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]